[Music]
rob kardashian makes a rare appearance
on instagram as he joins daughter dream
for his sister khloe kardashian's 38th
birthday getaway just family gathering
it's my birthday
[Music]
leading up to the celebration chloe
shares a video of true chicago and dream
running around on ear kylie and
seemingly showing a glimpse of rob
getting in on the fun
i love it rob also posts a series of
photos from the trip on his own page and
captions them paradise with dream
hashtag camp coco
the proud papa includes this snapshot of
dream effortlessly posing on a boat and
check out his baby girl having some fun
in the water smiling away with a cup of
juice in her hand living her best life
and last but not least
rob adds this rare photo of himself with
his feet kicked up
this outing for rob and dream marks the
first time he has been seen publicly
since his family won the defamation
lawsuit filed by dream's mom his ex blac
chyna and may
in june it was also announced that rob
and chyna reached an undisclosed
settlement in regards to her revenge
porn case against him
now while the drama seems to be
simmering down for her mom and dad
dream is busy showing off her
personality to the world
yes i want i wanted one and one and one
you're doing amazing sweetie
[Music]
yep that's the five-year-old delivering
one of grandma kris jenner's iconic
quotes
kim you're doing amazing it pushes me
out as a duo team up for a new amazon
commercial that dives deeper into fun tv
moments from the kardashians
including poking fun at the time when
chris was asked by ellen to say all of
her grandchildren's names
and she forgot one
mason penelope reign
north saint chicago psalm
stormy
wolf
um hold on dream
um
how many is that you're missing one help
me i'm missing one uh-huh said dream
um true yes oh true i love you so much
yes yeah so what's on the agenda today
boss reading a book
drawing a picture playing a game let's
play memory match
i actually have a great memory i can
remember the names of all of my children
and almost all of my grandchildren
cute
dream also gives a nod to one of her
aunt kourtney kardashian's go-to
catchphrases so what's the latest just
living life my vibe right now is just
living life
and she shows off her sense of style
along with her winning attitude
and that brings us to number three be a
good sport because winning isn't
everything again oh you better believe
it
go dream
[Music]